[Music]
catherine good morning how are you
hey dr daloni i'm doing good what are
you doing
you having fun uh you could say that
um i wanted to ask you this relates to
having fun
i'm exhausted um i have a newborn
and i know i've heard you talk a lot
about postpartum depression
yes and so coming out of giving birth i
was kind of anticipating that
and i did not realize that postpartum
anxiety was a thing
and so i was the worst your thoughts
on that well number one
i feel like i always have to give this
disclaimer disclaimer
i haven't nor will i ever have a kid
i've never experienced this and there's
nothing worse than some
man somewhere giving a woman advice on
how her body should be feeling
that's super annoying right can we all
just agree on that is that cool same
team same team okay good
now i have sat and walked alongside
a bajillion not a bajillion that's a
little bit overstated
um a number of women who
again have never experienced any of
these i have heard more
horror stories about postpartum anxiety
than i have postpartum depression
okay that it is brutal
um walk me through some of your
experiences
um okay well there's been a few
[ __ ] hold on just you are the most
lovely person i've talked to today and i
talked to james
i talked to james and he's usually the
most lovely you are because
you're like okay i'll describe it and i
know you're about to describe some
really awful stuff
in your spirit you're just oh you're so
wonderful okay
so go for it how is your little one by
the way
she is five weeks she was born premature
though so
she's like two basically like two weeks
if you if we went full term
so um that in and of itself had some
anxiety tied to it but
the kind of what more i'm looking for
advice on is
so like for example kind of uh
the two things that really get to me the
most are at night like when i'm trying
to sleep
and then when i'm driving in the car and
like i'll be
driving this is probably the best one to
start with i'll be driving and like
she'll be in the back seat and i'll just
be thinking like i haven't heard her
make a noise in a while i need to like
pull over and see if she's okay
or like i just think in my head like oh
what if we get in a car accident and
then she just
i mean she's in her seat so she nothing
should happen but i just
think like oh this is gonna happen or um
at night it's kind of the same thing
where i'm like trying to sleep
but then i think oh well she's making a
lot of noise maybe she's not breathing
okay or
or the opposite i'll say i i haven't
heard her maybe she's not breathing at
all
and then i just like i can't sleep or
i'm like constantly like trying to wake
my husband up like hey can you go check
on the baby
and it's just exhausting
never mind the fact that i'm just not
sleeping but it's exhausting to be
constantly thinking like
something is wrong or something is about
to be wrong
and if i'm not fully present
there you know it's going to be all my
fault and then
she's going to be gone and all this
stuff yes yes yes so number one thank
you for saying those things out loud
because i know they're scary to say out
loud
right um and they make you feel crazy
and in the moment they feel
super real right so it's both hands
right
um have you had any intrusive thoughts
about that the thought just pops in your
head like about hurting the baby or
about just running out the door
and leaving i mean have you had any of
those too or is it mostly the ruminating
in the worst casing
it's mostly the worst casing and i would
say
like it really comes and i just can't
get it out of my head like
another example and that's it's a little
bit more extreme i
think um the first day that i was home
by myself
with the baby there was like a
tornado warning and i literally was like
one foot in the bathroom one foot out of
the bathroom like i can't hear the
i can't hear the sirens i don't know if
there are sirens at all
and i couldn't i just couldn't get past
this like what do i do
do i stay in the bathroom for the next
six hours
so that in case i can't hear the sirens
were okay
or like you i just i just couldn't
function as really good word to put like
i just couldn't do anything i
kind of that's right what do i do that's
right yeah so
i've got good news for you okay
you're not crazy thank you
you're right exactly where you need to
be and it's super frustrating
and annoying and exhausting
and you're you're okay okay
all right so the the nerd word for worst
casing is catastrophizing
and worrying like ruminating it feels
like
you're those are productive thoughts
because you're just
on a loop right on a record player
that's going 100 miles an hour
but you feel like you're it's good
thinking because you're trying to solve
problems
like i'll just do this and i'll turn the
wheel this way and if this happens
i'll just get up i'll just get up i'll
just get up right so
um and then you you said it so perfectly
those lead to not sleeping
which then set off your every anxiety
alarm you have because sleep is the
magic cure
for almost everything right and
then you're not sleeping and then you
wake up
ding dong who's dead asleep next to you
because he doesn't know any of this is
going on
and he wants to be like great husband
but doesn't even know what that means
and
so he gets up and stumbles through and
then you feel guilty for waking him up
right and then the whole thing just
loops and loops and then tell me if i'm
crazy
then you end up a little more on alert
and the best place to go when you're on
alert is a screen
to just scroll the news or to scroll
netflix and just to watch things because
that's so good
and then you feel nuts and
you spend a lot more time by yourself is
all this ringing a bell
yeah okay so here's the thing
i'm going to give you a couple of things
you can do while you're in the middle of
all this and a couple of things you have
to do
is that cool okay yeah all right number
one be
really really nice to my friend
catherine
okay she has a five week old baby at her
house is this baby number one
yes yes everything you knew before now
is all stupid
right yeah this matters so
much and then you have a kid nope when i
have a kid it's going to look like this
nope i'm going to have this glorious
pregnancy
and my husband's going to hold my hand
it's all going to be the term
and all the music is going to be playing
and the essential oil whatever things
you uh
none of that happened right early right
was the c-section unplanned
um yeah okay it wasn't a c-section but
um
yeah it was not planned but early labor
yeah no it wasn't planned okay so one
day you're just b-bopping along and then
you were like oh no this is happening
okay
so none of those pictures look like you
thought they were going to look
okay and that's okay what i want you to
do is i want you to write down what you
were hoping was going to happen
and then smile real big and write down
with your hand
not on on a computer write down what
actually did happen
because it's beautiful too it's just
different
that's right right and you got to make
peace with the gap between what you
thought and hoped was going to happen
and the way you drew it up the way
pinterest said this all works
and then the just babies going to do
what they're going to do
on when it comes to delivery right and
then yeah
when you're driving when you are
spinning out at night
when anxiety comes over you the worst
thing you can do with anxiety is try to
fight it
anxiety can't kill you okay so
when you have those thoughts in your
head like oh my gosh i'm getting a wreck
and you start holding the
the the steering wheel tighter right and
you keep checking the rear view mirror
checking and checking and checking
katherine your baby's okay what i want
you to do there is to say these words
i'm anxiety right now or i'm worrying or
come up with some word that has more
swear words in it that's the way i would
do it
just call it out that it's happening and
what that does for you is it separates
the immediate fear as though a lion is
coming after you
it separates that towards oh my body's
just lost its mind again
it's weak it's recalibrating because it
grew a human
and then shot it out and now it's all
trying to restore itself right so just
acknowledge there's a gap between
reality there
oh my gosh my brains on a merry go round
again
and then just ride the merry-go-round
until it stops
is it frustrating yes is it exhausting
yes
but it will stop and when it
i gotta get up i gotta get up i gotta
get up begin to
gently lean into the third thing is
i want you to write your fears down and
then demand evidence from them
okay okay is there a possibility i'm
going to speak really honest with you
okay
is there a possibility that your
child is asleep and stops breathing yep
there is
sids it's real right
is it likely to happen no it's not
not even close to statistically could it
happen
yeah but probably not and what you're
experiencing now
is the utter risk and beauty
and joy and terror of loving something
so much
and being like letting your heart just
out walk around into the world
and this is being apparent it's terrible
and the greatest wonderful thing in the
whole wide world
so i want you to write down these fears
and i want you to demand evidence from
them
could you get in a car wreck yeah is it
going to happen almost
almost almost in no way
right probably not yeah and then the
last and most
important thing is i want to make sure
that you've got people in your life have
a couple of people you can text do you
have a couple of
friends girlfriends of yours that have
had kids before that have been down this
that you can text and say ah
and they'll just write back and then
that's it
yeah i do okay i want you to
call them and say you are now my go-to
you are my whatever don't give me
terrible advice but just tell me i'm not
nuts
okay okay and i've watched several women
that i care about and folks i don't even
know that well there's been a
relationship with
that have used that to it's just been
such a gift
right at 11 o'clock at night is my body
gonna always
and they'll be like nope and you go okay
good
and is my husband gonna always nope well
some husbands are idiots but
is this gonna hap nope right is my baby
going to and i can write back
yeah probably and one day you're gonna
wake up and be a rash and you're gonna
think it is end times
it is the world is over right and you
can text your friend a picture of it and
they'll say
no that's just this and you'll go ah
okay right so having a gang with you
and that gang's got to include your
husband and this is what i want you to
do i want you to make sure you're
communicating with him
not in the middle of the night not when
you're exhausted not when he's all
trying to be
hero or whatever um
set aside some intentional time that
y'all can just talk through your whole
worlds are different now
he is going to try to imagine when it's
going to go back to when the things were
when y'all just hooked up in the middle
of a tuesday afternoon because he came
home from work early and
when y'all just got in the car and drove
for a weekend somewhere he's going to be
trying to drag the past
into like whenever we're going to get
back to that you hear people say like
whenever coven's over
we can just get back to it's like homie
ain't coming back it's a new world
and then you are gonna have this picture
of
oh it's just gonna be three of us and
we're gonna go on walks with the
stroller and you're gonna walk home and
that idiot's gonna be sitting there with
a video game controller in his hand or
something
and you're gonna lose your mind right so
make sure y'all are communicating
regularly about hey how are you this
week
how are things this week what did we
think it was gonna look like and how is
it different
it's never gonna be um the way you all
drew it up and that's okay
what's the only not okay thing is if
y'all aren't talking about it
because then you're gonna grow together
and then that's when you're gonna say
man you've been picking up that
controller a lot
are you freaked out to have a new little
baby girl in your house and
he'll say yes i'm scared and then you
can say you're dumb
go hold your daughter he'll go play and
vice versa he could say hey i've seen
you just scrolling on your phone a lot a
lot a lot a lot lately are you doing
okay
and then he can say no i'm not you can
say to him i'm not i'm actually pretty
anxious i'm nervous
a big important caveat here catherine is
this
if the anxiety gets heavy if you get to
where you're not sleeping for night at
night a night or night on end
make sure you're being honest with your
doctor okay make sure you talk to your
doctor about these things when you go in
for your checkups
when you're going for the baby's checkup
absolutely and nothing you've told me
makes me think you're broken in a shape
form or fashion you're
exactly where you should be you've got a
new beautiful baby
five month old girl everything's
different now
everything's chaos your body's still
adjusting your brain and heart still
adjusting your house is still adjusted
everything's adjusting
but make sure you're being open and
honest with your doctor too if things
get scary
go see your doctor things get
uncomfortable
things get dark make sure you reach out
i'm so grateful for your call
congratulations
and come visit us in nashville and make
sure you bring that little baby girl
i'm gonna give you a couple of copies
i'm going to kelly's going to send them
to you
a couple of copies of my redefining
anxiety book
there's not a postpartum section in
there because i'd be an idiot if i wrote
that
but there is some really clear things
you um
you can learn about anxiety what you can
do about it and i'm going to send you
two because i want your husband to read
one too
and look him in the eye and say re read
this for me and he will because he's
trying he doesn't know what to do
but it will help him give a picture of
you and he's probably anxious too
okay thank you so much for your call and
your bravery and
your baby girl is so so fortunate to
have you
as her mom